on the great western balls of Africa is
Liberia Africa's only republic
during the past quarter-century
Liberia's importance as a referee
producing nation has gained for her
stature and recognition throughout the
world in Liberia today are millions upon
millions of rubbery trees the majority
of which produce more latex than any
other trees anywhere
operate the immense plantations on which
these trees are grown requires the
combined skills and labor of tens of
thousands of workers the health and
well-being of whom are vitally essential
to the welfare of the nation as a whole
safeguarding the health of her rubber
workers is both an economic necessity
and a moral obligation
in a very real sense the development of
research in and practice of tropical
medicine in Liberia is a byproduct of
forever expanding rubber industry as
rubber is vital to Liberian economy so
is an adequate medical program essential
to her progress and prosperity
in order to understand the nature of the
medical program that is today underway
in Liberia one must first examine the
country itself located barely above the
equator on the edge of the vast
rainforest of Equatorial Africa Liberia
is climate is humid and generally warm
the rainfall is heavy between 90 and 160
inches each year
the abundance streams and rivers
resulting from this heavy rainfall keep
the numerous valleys fertile and burden
and provide favorable conditions for the
growing of almost any crop even the
three or four month dry season fails
seriously to [ __ ] Liberia's abundant
agriculture or even then there are
usually enough showers and light rains
to maintain favorable group with the
climate so ideally suited to agriculture
it is not surprising to find Liberians
and agrarian people living close to the
land and engaged in pursuits that are
intimately related with the necessities
of everyday living most librarians are
tribes people who work and live very
simply their daily activities are
devoted largely to taking care of their
immediate needs these respects their
typical of native inhabitants of many
tropical climates
agriculture is inherently easy because
of the soils fertility and the fact that
crops are not severely restricted to
seasons even on casual inspection of the
landscape it is evident that here almost
anything will grow
on the one hand this lush productivity
resulting from the climate and rainfall
is a blessing on the other it is a
threat a menace and a liability for the
same conditions that make for an
abundance of vegetables forest products
and flowers are also favorable to the
growth and development of the micro
organisms that cause ruinous diseases
for example while some of Liberia
streams are pure others play a grim role
as carriers of malicious dysentery and
many other waterborne diseases to help
prevent these and to reduce the
continuous hazard of malaria by various
sanitation program today calls for
almost incessant spraying of surfaced
streams and the land around them
before the advent of the Firestone
rubber plantations swamplands and
stagnant pools provided ideal breeding
places for enough alene mosquitoes the
carriers of malaria today with a broad
medical and sanitation program in
progress this stagnant water is
methodically drained to prevent the
formation of larvae a breeding pool
foliation trees along rivers and streams
are cleared in order to fight
trypanosomiasis or African sleeping
sickness at its source this kind of
growth provides shelter and breeding
areas for the tet Sea Org la scene
applies several species of which are the
carriers of this baffling and frequently
fatal disease agricultural projects such
as the growing of rubbery trees also aid
in the elimination of texif life reading
areas
today in heavily populated plantation
areas water is impounded filtered and
chlorinated to make it usable for
cooking and drinking preventive measures
like these are doubly important on the
rubber plantations because of the
congestion that accompanies both working
and living on the plantations thousands
work together in close proximity in the
interior many native villages are
frequently overcrowded once it takes
hold almost any disease becomes a
potential epidemic
it is with this realization that
sanitary preventive measures like the
daily inspection of latrines have been
instituted on the plantations and are
rigorously enforced
but by far the most effective preventive
factor is immunization for example twice
yearly the resident population of the
Firestone plantations numbering about
40,000 is vaccinated against smallpox
which is endemic to much of Liberia each
native village has at least one dresser
station staffed by trained medical
orderlies to administer first aid care
for minor ailments and make simple of
diagnosis
the orderlies also make mass surveys of
diseases here they are making
preliminary tests for African
trypanosomiasis or sleeping sickness by
examining the cervical glands in the
back of the neck
unless acutely ill triads people rarely
seek medical aid an unbalanced diet
accustomed them to fatigue and low
metabolism and feel liable even to
recognize the presence of early symptoms
of disease
this plantation were here complaining of
an acute abdominal pain which he has
suffered for four days has come to his
local grocery station only because the
pain is intense
the orderlies unable to diagnose the
case adequately send him to the
plantation base hospital for further
examination by an American doctor once
daily or more frequently as necessary a
hospital Plus whose route covers all
plantation grocery stations transports
such patients to the base hospital
to the hospital come many abdominal
cases physical illnesses such as various
strains Ruthie's and fractures are
common partially this results from an
unbalanced diet which is frequently
deficient in protein
patience referred to the hospital by the
local station order lives are examined
first in the outpatient department of
the hospital the native medical
personnel on the firestone plantations
are about 100 in number all of them have
been trained by american doctors and
nurses who direct the hospital staff
in the outpatient department a competent
American doctor examines the abdominal
case and diagnoses repetitively
as a mimic abscess of the liver
after diagnosis the doctor orders the
patient admitted to the hospital for
surgical treatment
in the early part of the medical program
natives were dubious of what they termed
foreign doctors but their doubts and
fears were dispelled as a result cure is
affected and the obvious efficiency of
modern medical techniques and equipment
from the outpatient department the
abdominal case is admitted to the
surgical ward in this base hospital
first blood samples are taken from which
blood counts and blood tests will be
made
the blood tests themselves are made in
the hospital laboratory by skilled
native technicians the laboratory
facilities in the Firestone hospital in
Liberia are completely modern in all
respects
an x-ray examination is made to confirm
the preliminary diagnosis the pattern of
common diseases is such that the
preliminary diagnosis is generally
accurate but there have been instances
where x-rays have altered the early
diagnostic examination
in this case of abscess of the liver
surgery was considered advisable
equipment sterilization and medical
skills attended the farm surgery in the
firestone hospital compared favorably
with those existing anywhere the
extremely higher percentage of
successful surgery attests to the
validity of modern medical techniques in
primitive surroundings
only biases here undergoing operative
treatment is highly prevalent in most
tropical countries a waterborne disease
it is a development of chronic amoebic
dysentery the surgical objective is that
of training the hepatic abscesses any
biases affect an average of 40 to 50
percent of the entire native population
because of polluted water
the phrase Tropical Medicine indicates
cosmopolitan medicine it comprises the
great majority of diseases common to the
temperate climates and in addition a
relative few which are peculiar to the
tropics the deep tropics are the most
abundant of all pathological
laboratories
after surgery the patient is removed to
the convalescent ward where the care he
received differs little from that
operating hospitals in Des Moines
Hartford Tucson Portland New Orleans or
San Diego
the plantation hospital is staffed by
American doctors and nurses and is
supplemented by a native personnel most
of whom have learned readily and
function devotedly at a highly competent
level the case is most frequently
encountered in the general wards are
malaria's schistosomiasis carried by
water snails yours
Pena's right here intestinal worms
dysentery is general IOC's traumatic
injuries and pulmonary bone and skin
diseases
in pleasant easy surroundings the
patient recovers rapidly the period of
convalescence for this type of operation
is usually 10 to 14 days during the time
he's convalescing the patient also
receives intensive medical therapy
when discharged this young man is an
ambassador but will for modern medicine
in the tropics or back in his tribal
village he will report good food good
care and his speedy recovery
as elsewhere many diseases encountered
in tropics require isolation the beds in
this isolation hospital on the Firestone
plantations are frequently filled with
such highly contagious diseases as
smallpox and tuberculosis are these
small pox is the more common here are
three typical cases
in this case the disease is in an early
stage as indicated by the cutaneous
lesions or skin eruptions
this case a middle-aged woman is more
advanced
this is a confluent hemorrhagic type of
smallpox and is characterized by the
formation of large pustules over the
entire skin surface this case was
reported late and terminated safely
the third case a young boy is recovering
from the disease the deep pigmented
areas are typical of the recovery stage
in the General Hospital are always a
variety of diseases some cosmopolitan
some exclusively tropical
here is a rare case of sarcoma of the
clavicle a cancerous bone tumor
following the failure of surgical and
x-ray treatment the patient died
elephantiasis a complication of
filariasis is it almost exclusively
tropical disease this elephant is Rotem
weighing 42 pounds was successfully
removed by surgery and the patient
discharged mentally and physically
improved
here is a rare clinical example of Gallo
Messier the development of a female
memory gland in a man this developmental
anomaly was corrected surgically with
complete success
a dangerous disease largely confined to
tropical Africa is fraternal alliances
or sleeping sickness unless treated
early this disease is usually fatal
here a medical technician punctures a
lymph gland of a native worker whose
listless appearance and enlarged
cervical glands are symptomatic of
sleeping sickness
in this particular case the gland just
smear subjected to microscopic
examination revealed the three panel
songs which identify this disease
besides being a public health problem
certain types of tree panel so meiosis
constitute a major economic drawback
because they destroy draught animals and
other valuable livestock for more
routine public health measures some
forty dispensaries staffed by hospital
trained attendants serve the population
of the plantations evidence of the
success of the entire medical program is
found in the confidence it has
engendered many who once feared the
techniques and paraphernalia of modern
medicine are today willing and eager to
accept its benefits
much of Liberia's progress in medicine
and public health is due to the
industrial statesmanship of Harvey as
firestorm founder and RVs Firestone jr.
now head of the worldwide Firestone
organization
a gift from that organization enables
the American Foundation for tropical
medicine to establish in Liberia a
permanent Research Center for service to
Tropical Medicine general mr. firestorms
approval of the models for this Liberia
Institute was a mild storm in Tropical
Medicine world-famous medical
authorities and educators have agreed to
assist American Foundation for tropical
medicine in directing the Liberia
Institute continued research increasing
facilities and the application of the
best available skills are vitally
important to life and progress both in
the tropics and out for topical medicine
whose scope at first glance may appear
limited is actually of basic importance
to all peoples and all economies the
work already accomplished in Liberia has
extended the horizons of general medical
knowledge progress in tropical medicine
means progress or business or science or
humanity the goals are the maximum that
can be attained better health better
housing and food improve agriculture and
trade adequate water supplies and
general sanitation
yes even better transportation and more
efficient labor in short the objectives
of Tropical Medicine are those of all
medicine healthier and happier people
living better with a firmer grasp of the
present and confidence in the future a
future which the skills of modern
medicine will have made increasingly
secure